[Music]
hey
so i'm sure a bunch of you have never
heard of node who watched the corridor
crew here some of you watching us like i
know node
so node is another channel that we
started way back in 2012 basically at
the beginning of our youtube careers it
was never
actually specifically corridor it was
always a separate entity it was myself
dee sam brandon back in the day freddie
as well
we had a bunch of crazy experiences on
that channel we went on a bunch of
adventures at a bunch of really cool
things
what the hell freddy your job was to
build as a whole
it's been a while since we've been
posting videos on node you've probably
been wondering why
well it turns out we gave the channel to
d
he knew that going into this this isn't
a surprise i tried to act surprised but
wow
running a game channel is very hard as
the showrunner my job was to make sure
that sam
and nico had time to do their own thing
so that they could run corridor
corridor crew so brandy could run his
game development studio
my job was to make sure node ran and
videos got shot and edited and uploaded
so fast forward and sam nico are running
three different channels and they're all
doing really well
and they don't have time for node and
they're like you know we need somebody
who can take care of node and focus all
of the energy into the channel so they
thought that i would be a good pick
because it's either that or let the
channel die i've been running my own
channel for over a year now and i've
learned
so much from that i've learned so much
from these guys and i'm hoping to bring
that to node make some really awesome
content for you guys but we have one
requirement i knew there was going to be
something that's right i'm changing the
deal
i'm changing the deal yeah you promise
me
that you'll continue to host a yearly
smash for this tournament on the channel
[Music]
you guys are too good at smash you play
literally every day three times yeah you
play three times a day
i can't ever get to the point where i
can hold my own even if
you're the best at smash brothers the
moment that tournament starts like the
nerves hit and yeah even the best
players can fall to a new player
those are still some of my favorite note
videos we do and passed out in the last
one and dean
dean has won the championship nothing
gets you hyped like a fighting game
tournament
especially with everyone that you work
with definitely down dude easy i'm
really excited to get back into doing
airsoft videos
i want to do a dmd campaign as well i
had a lot of fun on son of the dungeon
and really got my juices flowing i've
learned a lot from sam
i've been doing a little practicing here
and there and i have a cursed straw
campaign that's basically
fully mapped out you know maybe finally
sam will get to be a player it's in many
moons
i'm really just excited about the fact
that these excited about working with
this channel again because we've all put
a lot of work into it
these last few months have been really
difficult because you know we're trying
to make so much cool
content here with our own channels that
we feel like
node deserves the same and we've made
some crazy videos
let's go let's go let's go
reloading damn i got contact we know
what you guys like
we know
yeah there's only 200 points we're going
to be re-innovating we're going to be
defining the next generation of video
game videos
[Music]
it's what we're all really passionate
about i'm just i'm so excited to
continue
you like cool things like airsoft and
nerf games and live action games you
just like adventures
head over to node subscribe if you
unsubscribe from doggo then resubscribe
there's a link in the description below
youtube.com
node this is a new face of node so if
you're subscribed
unsubscribe and then resubscribe again
to mark that change
that would like really [ __ ] up the
youtube algorithm probably yeah they'll
be like
wait everyone's subscribing or
subscribing is this good everyone
unsubscribes
but it got a lot of subscriptions what
does that mean
very controversial video yeah there's
one big bear video where they're playing
nerfs
very very controversial
so there it is guys i'm really excited
for this new chapter of the channel i
know a lot of you guys are old fans some
of you guys might be new fans most
importantly
is i want to keep the spirit of what
makes notes special alive good friends
hanging out playing games having a great
time and doing it with you guys because
you know what
at the end of the day what really
matters isn't how many subscribers you
have or how many views you get
it's about the friendships that you make
and the memories that you keep so this
video is for everyone out there who have
been asking what's happening where's
node
are they back yeah i'm back
[Music]
you